for a 17th straight year now the animal  foundation is named  it's best in show yesterday's event it  is the biggest fundraiser of the year  for the group  this year's show though it was online  and for the first time the public was  able to vote  so charlie this beautiful guy there  that's a bernice mountain dog  he won the large dog category this is  lola a terrier she was our pet of the  week  she won the small dog group and this  terrier sparky  won the medium dog category as well as  overall best in show  but all 24 dogs who were there this year  they were all winners because all of  them  were adopted and they're all so cute yay  john they got snacks which is even more